Peter L Bergen author of holy war Inc
inside the secret world of Osama bin
Laden you say on page 31 further
clouding our understanding of bin Laden
is the fact that a vast amount has been
written about him a good deal of it
rubbish
well I think you know when right-wing
rubbish is rubbish you call a spade a
spade a spade and you know I mean
they've been a lot of reports that bin
Laden was womanizing and drinking when
he was a teenager in Beirut it's very
hard to disprove er you know it's very
hard to disprove something that didn't
happen but you know as far as I can tell
he was a sort of very religious teenager
the reports that somehow bin Laden was
funded or trained by the CIA these these
are failed all sorts of common-sense
tests apart from anything else you know
if you if you were the CIA case officer
who ran bin Laden most of those people
would be a retirement age now you've got
a 20 million dollar book contract right
there I mean you know when conspiracies
happen and would you know iran-contra
these kinds of conspiracies people talk
about them so the notion that somehow
CIA was involved in training or funding
bin Laden who was a had a lot of his own
money he was pathologically
anti-american from an early age it sort
of defies common sense financially you
actually name the publications and went
specifically to the point they were
making jane's intelligence review which
reported that bin Laden may have
obtained an engineering degree in the
United States and was financed by the
CIA even call it respectable why would
they publish something like that I think
that you know it's because bin Laden is
libel proof incommunicado his family
isn't speaking largely incommunicado and
and you know he's public enemy number
one you can write anything that kind of
a precursor to you and I mean I think
the the bar about you know if that let's
say jane's intelligence review was
writing about let's say Jim Woolsey or
some well-known Intel you know they they
would be able to check these things I
mean they would find out where did mr.
Woolsey go to school and you know the
James just repeated something that was
sort of hearsay and you know it's a very
good publication but I think I wasn't
trying to single them out I'm just
saying that there's been a lot of stuff
written about bin Laden not all that
very accurate you mentioned Yosef
Podolski yeah who had a best-seller for
a while
it was on the it may still be on as far
as I know yeah he say one of examples of
misinformation about Milan can be found
in the tone by Joseph boudin ski who
enjoys the title of director of
Congressional Task Force on terrorism do
you know what that is it's a Republican
toss rules from terrorism says in bin
Laden the man who declared war on
America by danske describes the teenage
bin Laden visiting Beirut to drink
womanizing get involved in brawls ever
did that
not according to people who know those
who know bin Laden however described a
deeply religious teenager who married at
the age of 17
but as he makes another fantastic
assertion at the 1996 crisis of TWA 800
which killed 230 was a joint operation
between Iran and bin Laden yeah
no proof at all ever that ever happened
I mean TWA 800 went down for reasons
that the NTSB of natural Transportation
Safety Board and the FBI concluded was
an accident all right exactly care why
the accident but I mean trying to pin
bin Laden you know for the TWA 100 or
Iran it's just it's I don't think it's
very responsible for somebody who works
you know for Congress how did you then
go about making sure that and you've got
so many connecting points in this book
that it was accurate I tried to you know
like any book and they were probably
fact you know they're probably errors of
you know in that but I you know I try to
be somewhat responsible about what I put
in or you know basically the the
threshold had to be that's a
sufficiently high you know having worked
at CNN you know first a sa working at
CNN I mean what what that's this sort of
tradition I come out of so I've tried to
sort out some of the myths and some of
the rumors and try to really actually
report and actually go and meet the
people who met new bin Laden or they
were involved in his group in some way
or the people who were tracking him and
rather than relying on secondary sources
obviously I do rely on secretary sources
but I try and rely on secondary sources
that are either you know reputable
publications or books or you know trial
transcripts I mean I think court
testimony is a very useful in the you in
the Embassy bombing attacks the
subsequent Manhattan trial there was
about I don't know it must be every page
generated 150 every day generated
hundred 50
pages of testimony and there were about
70 days so there was a wealth of
information in those in those court
transcripts I used those and been trying
to talk to as many people on lot
different sides the story as possible
whether there are American government
officials people who were broadly
sympathetic with bin Laden Arab
journalists who've met with him or know
about him
Pakistanis you know I mean the way to
get a complete picture of the talk as
many people as possible obviously you
went to his father's village yeah when
did that happen where is it what did you
find it's a it's a beautiful place in
the Hydra mark which is a very remote
area of Yemen in eastern Yemen and it
looks perhaps a little bit like Arizona
it's so that it's sort of the mesas
almost as cliffs and that there's a
honey honey colored cliffs and in one of
these at the end of one of these valleys
you can find the town of our bat which
is bin Laden ancestral village and it's
you know about 5000 people it doesn't
you know if you go there as a Westerners
you know you're kind of kind of a big
deal I mean here the key all the kids in
the village because you know start
running after you and you know it's not
something that's not a place that's
regularly visited bin Laden left bin
Laden's father left the village when he
was a young man to go and seek his
fortune in Saudi Arabia but the family
retains some links to the village they
gave some money for occasion project and
there is a house there which is the bin
Laden bin Laden Street which is this
rambling old decrepit place which now
houses kind of an extended family some
of them are distant relatives of a sama
bin Laden and it's so big that part of
its the village school but I went there
with the John Byrne's of the New York
Times who who's a wonderful reporter and
we went to go and talk to some of the
remaining cousins who who are there what
does it mean if you're from Yemen what
what's that in that part of the world
over there were is it located what what
borders Yemen okay well to the south its
Arabian Sea and then to the north of
Saudi Arabia so a lot of Yemenis went to
Saudi Arabia because basically to get
Yemen is a very very poor country I
think it's the poorest country in the
Middle East probably
and so you get a lot of immigration and
one of the people who emigrated was
Muhammad bin Laden the father of Osama
but he was part of a pretty big movement
and one thing that's interesting about
bin Laden's organizations you'll find
that some of the key people are Saudis
but they actually have Yemeni
backgrounds like like bin Laden himself
for instance the person who's regarded
as being the mastermind of the bombing
of the USS Cole in Yemen last year is
somebody who whose family originates in
in Yemen that grew up in Saudi Arabia
fought in Afghanistan like bin Laden
against the Soviets is there yeah how
close is Yemen to Afghanistan Yemen is I
mean quite some distance if you have to
go you mean it would be you'd have to
fly you know I know it's about 1,500 I
mean I'm guessing 1,500 miles a thousand
miles perhaps quite some way what's the
population of Yemen the population of
Yemen is 17 18 million one interesting
thing is that they am I getting confused
I think that I think the number of guns
in Yemen maybe that number and then the
population maybe there I think you I
remember statistics 65 million guns
right 18 million people does exactly
right that's right 65 million guns 18
million people so like FK me Yemen is a
lot very similar to Afghanistan it's I
mean physically it's very beautiful
mountains its deserts you know it's
tribal there is quite a there's been
quite a tourist industry in Yemen except
that has been impacted obviously by
terrorist events and kidnapping of
tourists but you know it's one of the
one of the seven wonders of the world is
the is the bazaar in Sinai Yemen
literally one of the seven wonders well
I think you UNESCO called it so and it's
really like stepping back into the
Middle Ages you see camels wearing
blinkers and they're trying to they're
making sesame oil on these giant mortars
and pestles and you see it's like a
scene out of some idiot medieval
painting but it's real I mean it's
happening now and it's it's so it's a
one of it's a wonderful place
unfortunately you know bin Laden's group
managed to function just you know pretty
well that I mean they were able to form
the USS Cole to her plans earlier this
year in June for some of bin Laden's
followers to bomb the US Embassy there
so
it remains a place where the pockets of
al-qaeda exist although the Yemeni
government has been apparently quite
cooperative within the United States
government in terms of trying to close
al Qaeda down there you point out in the
book that there was a an attempt at a
bombing the Sullivans yeah shipped the
Sullivans when did that happen and how
much of that do we know now how much of
its public well I mean quite a lot of
the USS the Sullivans was a sort of
dress rehearsal for the cold that
occurred on January 3rd mm which was
towards the end of Ramadan in that
particular year and basically what
happens the Bombers overloaded their
boats with explosives and it sunk but
they learned from their mistakes and
they came back and they did the USS Cole
but the the interesting thing about the
Sullivans attack was that or the planned
attack on the Sullivans was that it was
going to be part of a sort of terrorist
spectacular involving the bombing of Los
Angeles International Airport lax and
also bombing tourist sites in Jordan and
all these things going to be related for
the Millennium for the new millennium
and none of them actually worked out
either because of incompetence of the
plotters or good police work but it it
it shows a that al-qaeda has had his
share of failures as it were luckily but
be it shows the you know these rather
grand scale plans I mean this was a this
is a plan to kind of not simultaneously
but within the same time period you know
blow up an airport in America blow up a
u.s. warship in Yemen and also blow up
places associated with American tourists
in Jordan and it would have been pretty
devastating where do you think the US
intelligence has been in all this well I
mean you know it's very easy to Monday
Morning Quarterback because obviously
September 11th was the biggest failure
of intelligence gathering in American
history and it mean yeah no one can
argue with that fact on the other hand
it has to be said that US law
enforcement and the intelligence
community were knew a bin Laden was a
pretty serious character quite early on
as early as 1995 the prosecutors in the
Southern District of New York which is
basically handled a lot of the terrorism
case
is what the initial Trade Center bombing
in 93 for instance they were asking
people I did some you know in terrorism
trial do you know a sama bin Laden that
was in 95 and you know lawyers who were
in the case at that time said they were
kind of mystified why who was this
Islamic bin Laden even though they knew
a lot about the case why was that the
prosecutors were asking about him so his
name was beginning to surface in 95 for
American law enforcement and prosecutors
because his his name claim kept cropping
up too often I think is what happened
you know in by 96 the US State
Department's caught him in the most
significant finance here of Islamic
extremism in the world and actually had
a very detailed white paper about who
this guy is he has training camps in
Afghanistan Sudan and also I think round
about the same time the CIA founded its
own separate unit devoted to bin Laden
which is sort of an interesting you know
they there was a counter-terrorist
Center within the CIA and you know to
have set up this own this specialized
unit which has allowed a function
apparently in giving quite a lot quite a
lot of latitude to function without
having to deal with the Washington
bureaucracy so much you know so I mean
United States government was well aware
that bin Laden was a very dangerous man
on September the 10th you know he was
already on the ten most wanted list and
he had a five million dollar reward on
his head so unprecedented so it's easy
to sort of say well that was a huge
failure and on the other hand I mean
both statements are true it was it was
an intelligence failure but also the US
government you know had put a lot of
effort into going after him I mean the
fact is that he his group has sort of
soui generous I mean very unusual in the
sense that it was very disciplined and
very organized and you know if you think
about the Terrorism that happened
against American targets in the 80s it
was they were there was the Marine
Barracks bombing killed more than 200
Americans in 1983 where I was but it was
nothing never on the scale you know the
thing about this group is that they kept
making their plans more and more complex
and more and more deadly as time went on
one can only hope that you know the
trade center represents the apex before
I go on let me ask you some
questions about you yeah where were you
born I was born in Minneapolis
what year 1962 how long did you live
there
my parents we we my parents and the
family moved to Paris when I was three
and then we moved to London when I was
five about five or six nine how long did
you stay there lived in London Maine
basically my entire life went to high
school in Yorkshire and all the thing
that went to University of Oxford and
then came a returned to the United
States after I left University and why
did you go to Oxford um what'd you study
I studied history what kind of history
modern history which it also begins with
the anglo-saxons
and well I mean why did I go there I
mean it's an incredibly beautiful place
it was a wonderful time to go and your
modern college new college nuke oh yeah
and which is across the street a new
college just I think founded in 1369
whatever sale no but you know I had a
great time there I didn't really you
know there one of their about many
requirements to work really so and
everybody you know it was funny because
at that time the English government
actually paid for you go to university
they gave you you know I mean now you
have to pay or something yourself but at
that time not only was the education
free but they actually gave you money to
like cameras spending money so it's a
kind of a very different philosophy than
the kind of but of course now the
British government is asking people to
pay but it's still relatively speaking
very inexpensive British citizen or
American ships I'm American it did your
parents meet back here with you uh my
mother stayed in England for another I
guess 10 years and then she's moved to
Washington releve recently and my father
now this is an immune itíd state as well
so when you came here from Oxford
where'd you go
I moved to New York what'd you do I
became a messenger I had a job called
desk assistant which basically meant
dogsbody
at ABC News and and that was my first
job that it was a it was a very good way
to sort of get to know Manhattan because
you sort of you know just taking
packages here and also kind of a good
way to get to know the business because
you kind of
just by process of osmosis you kind of
began to learn a little bit about
business there's no reason to employ
somebody doesn't matter where they've
been to school if they don't know you
know so it was kind of like that's the
opening job you get and then you know
you kind of get promoted as you go along
what you do along just at ABC five years
and what did you end up being at ABC uh
I worked the my officer was the 20/20
where I was you know like production
assistant associate producer whatever on
different projects you know either the
20/20 was a very nice place to work
there were very nice people and I was
able to get we I met Ronald Reagan and
Nancy Reagan after they after Ronnie
Reagan had retired which was pretty
amazing as a kid to spend a day with him
he was exactly how are you you know he's
exactly how everybody said he would be
he was very charming and very pleasant
and Nancy seemed to completely run the
show and when did you decide to leave
ABC and where'd you go I've got a job
offer at CNN which was early in 1990 and
from wonderful my boss Pam Hill at the
time and she was setting up a unit at
CNN to do like you know documentaries
investigative pieces etcetera and I
decided to go there and turn out to be
quite good timing because the Gulf War
that happened and it was a great time to
be at CNN and and yeah I feel very lucky
that I was at CNN in Hawaii because you
know if you're interested in news where
where else better to be I mean this
that's what they do so in 1990 you would
have been how old I think I was 27 if
any son yeah so you've been there ever
since
uh yeah well except I resigned to write
the book two years ago go back to the
first time you ever thought about Osama
bin Laden I think the very first time I
really thought about it seriously was an
article by Judith Miller and Jeff Kurtz
and the New York Times ran about the
time the State Department releases kind
of rather detailed fact sheet about him
and I thought well that's kind of
interesting because it always seemed to
me that the bombing of the World Trade
Center was through it you know when
you're when you're a prosecutor there
was a rather narrow set of things you're
looking for I mean who bombed the Trade
Center and that and that question was
solved by the trials but who was behind
the bombing wasn't ever really asked
very seriously it didn't seem to me
perhaps because it was didn't seem that
necessary or whatever but it there was
something kind of odd about the people
they came from Peshawar Pakistan Ramsay
use of the mastermind they seem to have
money from somewhere they must have had
training to build these explosives I
mean who was doing all that I didn't
just suddenly show up in Brooklyn and
know how to build a huge bomb and you
know it turns out you know the more we
look at that case the more it's clear
that it was sort of a proto al-qaida
operation of year was all this did you
read that article
oh when I read the book the reason that
I when I read the article is 96 it just
the the Judith Miller Jeff curves piece
just sort of said it's it looked at
these Middle Eastern businessman
including bin Laden saying you know kind
of who are they so I went to my bosses
at CNN
Pam Hill and John Lane at the time and
and I said I'd be very you know I think
we should relook at this guy and they
had they had previously encouraged
documentary that I was involved in which
looked at the Trade Center bombing and
the air collection connections to
Afghanistan so they uh they encouraged
me to go and do the to try and find out
if we could meet with bin Laden and and
well I mean that was quite a performance
it was a we we went to but the the
initially I call this contact in London
somebody by the name of harlot alpha was
I said we were interested he said fine
either certain things I don't want to
chat about on the phone so I went to
London I spent about a week with him and
basically kind of laid out that we would
give bin Laden a fair hearing again what
URI does this is this is early 97 and
about a month I will submit with
somebody that was going to take us to
bin Laden if we if we map enemy it was
sort of like there was a certain sort of
screening process that was going on they
wanted to make sure that we weren't
agents of the American government in
some way or they also want to make sure
that we would kind of give him a fair
hearing you know explain that we would
give everybody a fair hearing and about
a month later I went back to Washington
we got the call saying you're on and I
myself and the correspondent Peter
Arnett went to London we met up with our
cameraman
and two other people who knew kind of
related to bin Laden they took us to
Pakistan where we yeah we kind of kept
going through a series of different
hoops about each each stage of the way
and finally finally we get to
Afghanistan which is the final hoop and
we are were in Jalalabad not too far
from where Tony from Tora Bora of course
where al-qaeda is presently hold on no
word had you been to Afghanistan before
that yes when I went in 93 for a quote
for quite some time during the war you
know the war in Afghanistan between the
forces of I mean there was a civil war
in Afghanistan even after the Communists
the Afghan communist were defeated which
is ripping you know the ironic thing is
Cobbold capital had basically survived
the whole communist without being
destroyed it was the Afghans themselves
to destroy it principally the googley in
heck Machar who was the prime minister
of the time it was probably the only
prime minister in history to be shelling
his own capital on a daily basis so I
was there in 93 during that during that
period we interviewed had made sure we
also interviewed Ahmed Shah Massoud who
of course is now dead unfortunately
and we that was in the context of trying
to find out how the Trade Center Bombers
in 93 how you know what their
connections to the Afghan war against
the Soviet Union have been so in 97 that
was that was the I been once before in
97 was the second time I went did you
sense at that time and based on your
study at Oxford in the history and all
that that this was a bigger thing than
most people were paying attention to no
I don't think so
I mean I I I did all the things that I
thought I've done because I was
interested in rather than sort of
thinking thisis going to turn into a big
story because I mean who and I got
interested in Afghanistan or Pakistan in
1983 when I was a student University we
a couple of friends myself made a
documentary about the Afghan refugees in
Pakistan who are you doing this for
we kind of did it on our own steam and
then we showed on channel 4 in England
after we kind of got it together and I
mean two people I was with you kind of
knew more them we didn't have anything
really between ourselves but we kind of
kind of the the innocence engendered by
you know being very young and optimism
and we sort of thought we could do this
so we shot it on film and then it was
shown on English television but anyway
the the don't got be interested in
Afghanistan or Pakistan I went back at
it with ABC News - we did a story in
Pakistan about the legal status of
Pakistani women which was obviously
pretty bad even under Benazir Bhutto who
was then prime minister at the time who
you know he wasn't really able to get
the religious parties to get off as
aware and liberalize the situation but
so I I did my channel my interest really
started was just being interested in the
country the place that the place is
rather than sort of an interest in
terrorism so go back to your year 97
you're on your way you're in up Pakistan
you're on your way to - you're in
Afghanistan I wanted all that take by
the way from the time you leave here -
the time they finally got you in country
I don't know it must have been receipts
of these phases at by the time we
actually I mean it could have must have
taken at least two weeks from Washington
to meeting bin Laden at lead say at
least two weeks and it's just you and
Peter Arnett in the camera version yeah
Peter Juvenal is a camera person who
actually is a former British Army
officer who spent more time in
Afghanistan as a journalist than anybody
else you sort of person who really here
Peters the line is you know any fool can
get into a difficult situation that it's
like getting out of it that is the
complicated part you know so being I
being Peter on out and Peter Juvenal
Cameron I've been to Afghanistan before
and they were there exactly the right
people in case something you know on
that obviously you know been in many war
situations and there were the right
people to have around if anything did go
wrong I would want that one of the
things that went wrong almost
immediately was that the week before we
went to see bin Laden the Taliban banned
the photography of any kind of person
yes sir so we sort of an in quandary
about whether to whether to go to the
country illegally and be thrown out
because we didn't have visas or you know
if you applied for a visa they're gonna
ask you what are you doing and you know
that's her in the end we decided not to
apply for visas and just go in and take
our chances and like a lot of things
that are never very clear in Afghanistan
it was never clear to me that the
Taliban I knew that we were there to
interview bin Laden and sanctioned at
all that they just couldn't care less I
mean they didn't really blend that
interest in who we were I mean we stick
out like a you know
it's pretty you're pretty obvious if
you're living in Jalalabad and in a
hotel for several days not really doing
anything it's like who are these people
but they never really asked us it was
kind of odd so how did you get to the
man himself that was that was um yeah
after we had a meeting with his media
advisor who basically said you looked at
our camera equipment and said you can't
take any of this because we're concerned
about bin Laden's security any kind of
electronic device that might give away
his location
they were very paranoid basically and so
he said well you can do your interview
but it'll have to be with our equipment
absent and there's no point arguing the
matter I mean it was either that or no
interview so you know we had a sort of
series of different trucks we went
everything we had a van and then as sort
of Jeep and we were blindfolded and it
was the middle of the night and you know
we were we went through various
concentric rings of security around bin
Laden we were searched in a professional
manner they basically made it clear at a
certain point if we had a tracking
device that if we told them now it
wouldn't be a problem but we told them
later it would be definitely a problem
when you had all afraid for your own
life in this situation no I profess well
they'd invited us you know they weren't
going to screw around with us and
secondly Mei rather than being
frightened I was actually quite thrilled
I mean not thrilled thrilled on what I
was happy that this was coming off I
mean it spent a lot of time and effort
trying to organize this and we were
there we were going to we didn't really
know how the whole thing was going to
end but it was you know something we
would all spend a lot of time and effort
trying to get to that point so the fact
that we were now going up the mountain
we were in we were we didn't know know
exactly we were work but I'm pretty sure
we were in the White Mountains where
that al Qaeda bases is it is located
near somewhere near there and how long
were you I mean what time of day did you
travel and how long would you travel any
given time I they arrived at dusk and so
there must've been around 5:00 p.m. and
I we weren't allowed to even take
watches so we weren't we had no idea
what time it was exactly but like III
estimated was sometime before midnight
when bin Laden finally showed up and he
wasn't going to hang around he just
wanted to do the interview and go I mean
he was
that he was with his entourage here how
many in his entourage I think I can't I
I counted a total of maybe 30 people
that I saw over the course of the night
maybe around him in the director
entourage or maybe on a 10 armed yeah
everybody everybody's armed and you know
some of them spoke pretty good English
and what was your sense of the kind of
people year around were they smart
people well I think they divided it two
groups there was there were some kind of
people who seemed not that smart who
were like kind of the protection people
more they just seemed like foot soldiers
and they seemed there were group of some
some middle-eastern faces and some
African faces and then there were some
people who were kind of in charge they
spoke very good English they seem to be
saudi there was a translator who spoke
impeccable english and that he repaired
maybe to be a cleric and yeah so i think
they divided up into kind of the people
who were just you know kind of the
muscle and then the people who are
running the show the interview itself
taped for how long about an hour we
peter arnett and I had worked up a lot
of questions for bin Laden and he didn't
want to answer anything about his
personal life his family his finances he
just wanted to talk about yeah why was
declaring war against the United States
which after all the reason that we were
there we were not there wasn't about his
family history we're trying to find out
who this guy is why is he declared war
against the United States and in a
nutshell you know he the main thing that
his main gripe is the continued presence
of American troops in Saudi Arabia which
he regards as infidels trust being it's
trespassing on the holy land
what did you see up close in in person
that you can't see on video and he those
were almost like feline aspect I mean
he's a he's not a kind of very macho
kind of guy at all he's more he was
pretty low-key and he didn't strike me
as being particularly I don't speak
Arabic so maybe there's more charisma
when you understand him in the
of tone but yeah you didn't have it he
doesn't have this like you know
lightbulb like personality or he doesn't
swagger he's very he's very he was very
he was almost you know you could barely
hear him speaking because he was so low
key I mean I think he was I think he had
a cold at the time but he he just came
off as being mild-mannered and what did
CNN do was the interview once you were
finished well we went back and we we
edited we didn't we we put the the text
of the entire interview on the internet
but we I mean we edited it down into a
20 minute really profile of who is this
guy and what is he doing or what has he
done what is he being accused of doing
and we use the best stuff of the
interview I mean any of you was you know
I mean you've seen bin Laden he sort of
he can ramble on a lot about stuff it
isn't that sort of germane in a way but
so we that interview there's this
profile ad in May of 1997 this is really
off the study but every time you when I
see these stories about folks like you
going up into the mountains and hours
and hours on the road the one question
is never answers where do you get you
gas but they were driving us where do
they get I mean a station alone well you
know uh I guess I guess they must they
must keep gas in the car I mean there
aren't I
view I mean there aren't many gas
stations in Afghanistan it's good
question I I don't know where but they
they certainly were driving around a lot
at night I mean they must keep jerrycans
and their jeeps or whatever but I hadn't
really occurred to me but go back to
Mohammed Daoud the father got back to
Yemen what year did he go to Saudi
Arabia 1930 and he founded the family
company of 31 and then the Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia was founded in 1932
although you know to the south the Saudi
family had been sort of gathering pieces
of the puzzle to make the kingdom but
and he became very close to King Fahd
and was able to build palaces and the
family renovated my
Medina what year did he die he died a 67
1967 when bin Laden was time and how
many wives did he have we only forward
in any given moment but I think my
understanding is perhaps up to ten or
eleven and how many children totaled it
here around 50 and worded Osama bin
Laden fit into that he's supposedly the
17th son he's the only he's the only son
of one of the mothers so they hear there
was a Syrian mother and bin Laden has
two full sisters but the family is
pretty large what I mean you know 5050
siblings of one stripe or another and
now of course is another generation so
those those kids have all had kids who
you know that somebody was sending me
that yeah there are like 200 plus first
cousins who are now make up the bin
Laden family and Osama bin Laden himself
you talk about the book head I think it
got a fourth wife after you saw him or
was that he got a fourth wife in the
early 2000 are they how do they when you
have four wives how do you deal with
them well the Koran says or the you know
is if you you're only supposed to take
as many wives as you can actually
support and for as the maximum so you
know if you obviously been answered the
resources to support four wives but you
know who those people who those wives
are exactly one of the most recent one
is is a Yemeni but there's not a hell of
a lot of information about bin Laden's
family there is a son called Abdullah
who lives in Saudi Arabia who's the
oldest who sort of rejected his father
and then there's also a very young
daughter I believe in Saudi Arabia for
maybe four what do you know about his
mother he said she was Syrian yeah she
apparently divorced the usamos father at
some point has since remarried she's in
pretty close touch with her son she's
visited him in Sudan when he lived there
between 91 and 96 and she was also at
our grandsons wedding which happened
early this year in Afghanistan so she
keeps in touch with her son any idea
what she's like no ever seen a picture
of her no I mean one thing you got on a
sign is that you know the notion of uh
sort of I mean a note that does say the
notion of a picture of Osama zwei for
women just yeah it would or an interview
with her Samas wife
thing like that is just you know it's
not going to happen what countries in
the world did Osama bin Laden live in
well Afghanistan Pakistan Sudan Saudi
Arabia where'd he get his education
Saudi Arabia at the he studied economics
and public administration and when did
he get his money well the dad dies his
father dies in 67 all the kids are
pretty young but even Assam his oldest
brother at that time would have only
been 20 and so the family company was
sort of put in trust and the estate was
only divided in the 80s and bin Laden
apparently got about thirty five million
dollars and I know that because I told
you somebody was somewhat privy to the
division of the estate is less than the
other estimates he had a lot more money
than that with fill thirty five million
dollars is thirty five million dollars
and then you know at the certain point
he became he becomes probably the
biggest businessman in Sudan between 91
and 96 is really a very intense period
of business one of them I say in the
book is almost holy war Inc really was
holy war ink in the sense that he had
this huge array of businesses from
tanneries to bakeries to banks to
construction businesses to trucking
companies to you know import-export
basically in cornering the market in
certain of Sudanese agricultural
products but at the same time running
these paramilitary camps and so you know
it when I call when I call the book holy
war rink that was one of the reasons I
mean with partly also play on the Murder
Inc notion but but also you know bin
Laden comes out of business background
yeah he studied economics his family's a
business is very successful he
established himself as a very big
businessman in Sudan the the the al
Qaeda the business of terrorism almost
was set up in a pretty rational manner
you know there were political arms and
religious arms and business arms and
media arm and I mean that all that's
gone now of course because al Qaeda is
about to he's about to go out of
business for a long time what's a summer
mean in English lion
what is al Qaeda mean the base and when
did he start it 1989 one you know the
basis of the base as it were
is that after the Soviets withdrew in
February 89 from Afghanistan Obon
unrecruited be all these people from
around the world four holy wars and they
all got some sort of military experience
and rub shoulders and got to know each
other and there's sort of is this
international cast of sort of holy
warriors as it were but all of them
wanted to do other you know change their
governments in their native countries
like Egypt or you know ferment a
rebellion and various other places or
eventually in Berlin's case attack
United States so al-qaeda became the
basis for the al-qaeda it sort of sprang
out of those all those people who would
travel to Afghanistan
oh go to the back to the reason that he
hates the United States yeah when when
can you when did you figure that it all
actually started it starts on a date
August the 7th 1990 imeem not that it
happened overnight
bin Laden being anti-american for a long
time where was he living then he was
living in Saudi Arabia and it was that
that was the day that President Bush
denounced Operation Desert Shield which
were event which effectively meant the
introduction of several hundred thousand
Americans into Saudi Arabia bin Laden
you know there were women you know I was
at worst women soldiers trespassing on
the hotel owners of sandy river that was
terrible as far as bin Laden was
concerned and the reason that it's yeah
one thing that makes it very clear to me
why several things is you know eight
years later that to the day Bernards men
blow up two US embassies in Africa
within the nine minutes of each other
and that was sending a very clear signal
I mean this August seventh moment was
very critical because eight years later
that that he that calls has been Laden's
biggest sort of terrorist outrage to
date so he was sending a message and you
know he's been very consistent about you
know these people are on the lines of
the Prophet Mohammed and they need to be
expelled and it's been very very been
very consistent about that whether it
was in the videotape that that indicates
that he's guilt in the trade center
where he mentions that this is you know
the this kind of thing or yeah all of
his public statements usually mentioned
this go back to the beginning again yeah
he said he had been given thirty five
million dollars and we've seen all kinds
of figures along the way
how much do you think he's been worth
over the years after the construction
company yeah it's hard to tell I mean
he's always had access to some money but
at the end of the day the money sort of
a bit of a red herring in the sense that
you know you can't it's not about money
it's about belief and the people that he
recruits to him aren't paid you know
they're volunteers and not mercenaries
and the people who die in these
operations clearly you can't there's no
amount of money he gives to somebody
like Mohammed Atta who came from a
prosperous Egyptian find himself anyway
to persuade him to fly a 747 into the
World Trade Center so I think the money
has been important but it's not been
vital to bin Laden's project what's been
vital is his ability to transfer a lot
of rage against the United States
perhaps you know taking the sort of
localized rage of people against you
know there are all sorts of Middle
Eastern governments which are
authoritarian and corrupt etc etc but
somebody else saying someone's saying
making the analysis I saw the United
States fall for all these problems and
getting people to go along with that
idea and being able to organize them and
recruit them and giving them the
training to become quite deadly these
are all as Bernards genius it's not his
money did have you met al Zawahiri no he
kept a low profile and number two is he
number two yeah he's alive
he shows up in the videotape across the
Trade Center where bin Laden takes
responsibility for the Trade Center it's
hard to tell me there were reports that
he was dead and they seem to be not that
accurate because families do oh yes the
family is dead apparently they took out
a death notice in some Egyptian
newspapers so you say in the book you
met art F yes
who was it well actually I didn't
actually meet with him I corresponded
with him who was he
he's not there now deceased military
commander he but I mean I didn't when I
was dealing with him I didn't really I
wasn't quite sure if he was the military
commander or not I thought that there
was that he was simply one of the media
advisors but apparently he's one of the
same person and we corresponded after
the attacks on the US embassies in
Africa and the subsequent cruise missile
strikes against bin Laden's camp in
Afghanistan and I was trying to get
another interview but we talked we
corresponded by fax from the Kabul post
office to my hotel room in pangas
and in the end they say the message came
but it wasn't they just didn't think it
was a good idea what about this book
when did you get the idea to do this
book and I know it was finished in
August and then of course now it you can
change it a lot by the time I got my
hands well I got the idea to write the
book I mean I always wanted to write a
book and it just seemed like a good I
mean to me it the the many things I was
interested in the subject and that kind
of subject is bananas and interesting
obviously was an interesting he's an
interesting personality and phenomenon
of course you know I didn't when I was
starting it I had no idea that you know
we'd be talking about September 11th or
events like this but I just thought that
if I was interested in the subject and
that somehow other people would be too
and you know I mean I think it's a
general proposition I think that's a
good way to operate I mean if I'm if
you're not interested or isn't
interested particularly who else is
going to care I mean you have to be you
have to think it's an interesting
subject you have to be engaged in it let
me ask you some minor book Destin's when
you originally wrote the book and finish
the August of this last of this year how
many copies of this were they going to
publish I'm not sure but they told me
they they read the manuscript they said
we're going to double projections now
doubling it from probably a very low
number you know it would have been I
don't know but the Free Press what ten
fifteen thousand I think they were going
to I think they were going to double it
from ten to twenty maybe let's say
hypothetically they never told me the
figures they said they were going to
double it to something beyond what they
previously thought the book was done and
you had it at the publisher in August it
wasn't done it was I handed in my
manuscript but it needed work on August
30th so what happened on September 11 uh
I think at a certain point I spoke to my
editor Rachel Clayman and said to her I
mean I don't know if it was on the 11th
or not because although the whole day
was so mad but we talked about you know
what are we going to do and you know
obviously to do is you know have all the
time is to get the book out it was now I
mean people wanted for a lot of people
bin Laden you know could have been shman
Laden I mean they'd never heard of the
guy they didn't own it this the events
of September 11th came like a bolt out
of the blue he was the most
it was a very beautiful day and it just
suddenly this thing happened it was like
how did that happen was almost
inexplicable but the fact is it was
explicable to some degree I mean soon as
the second plane hit to me it was I mean
it was who else who else would have had
the motivation and the kind of
organization to pull this off so we
talked I mean Rachel my editor was was
was yeah I can't remember very much of
the conversations because there were so
many things going on but we basically
you know agreed we just have to get this
done and that Rachel my editor very
kindly came down to Washington for about
four or five days and we just basically
worked I mean at certain point it's like
you can't have these conversations over
the phone you just have to be with your
editor and we just worked around a clock
to get it out and you've gone as far as
they have this note at the bottom of the
flap both author and publisher will
donate a portion of their proceeds from
this book to United Way's September 11th
point what's the percentage you're going
to give it I think it's a some routine
percentage M which is I mean industry
standard but what happened about that
the printing of this book how many
copies did you originally print and it
has been on the bestseller list um I
think it's they are they there now it's
a print run of 250,000 that doesn't mean
anything I mean doesn't mean you're
gonna sell 250,000 I mean there might be
you know a lot sent back I mean III know
more about publishing than I used to now
which is if you the point is you've got
to print more than you're gonna because
the worst thing is not to be able to
have it in the shops when you need it
but you know i think that i mean i i'm
hoping doing something of a service in
the sense that it the book may it may
help people understand their you know
since September 11th did not emerge out
of a vacuum this guy's been planning
these kinds of attacks against American
targets since the early nineties and his
organization has been involved in
attacks against Americans since the
early nineties and unfortunately what
happened is that these taxes got got
more complex and more and more deadly
and they've sort of you know this sort
of there was a kind of accelerated curve
upwards of attacks and you know it
hopefully the book will make that clear
I think that if if you've read the book
at the end of it when you put it down I
hope you
fine you said yourself now I kind of
understand how that wasn't entirely a
bolt out of the blue I think that bin
Laden by the way you know I think
September 11th he he wanted to provoke
some sort of Clash of Civilizations it
was a total failure the striking thing
to me but you can't justify the
September 11th attacks the Islamic let
me know in Islam this is no language to
justify it and bin Laden doesn't even
try and justify I mean when he says we
when people asked him why why these
assaults on American citizens he says
well they're America they pay taxes and
therefore that completes it but it's
hardly a sort of justification and
religious certification and you know
that his message has had a zero
resonance so very little in the Muslim
world you have not seen millions of
people getting on the streets saying
Osama Osama Osama on the contrary you
know the demonstrations have been tiny
and you've seen every middle-eastern
government lining up to help against bin
Laden because they understand he's a
threat to them and I think the videotape
you know if there was any doubt that he
was involved surely that would expunge
it and it makes it clear that he's a you
know a rather I don't know if it's hard
to find the words but it certainly a not
a very it's a breathe his joviality on
the videotape was was really pretty
unpleasant and he is he I tell you what
Brian what I think about him we've seen
a lot of his type in us in the past
century which is like um I know how to
create the perfect omelet and doesn't
matter how many Briggs eggs are
necessary to break to make that imam
muhammad and we've seen that again and
again and again i'm not talking about
you know whether that was Pol Pot or
Stalin or Mao these are all very
different people and then I can't
compare bin Laden to all these people in
the sense that his victims are I mean
his victims are his victims and but they
all share one at one absolutely common
thing which is I know how to create
paradise on earth I'm absolutely certain
about it and if other people don't
understand that you know sort of they're
wrong and only that they we should be
able to kill them and you see that again
and again the worst person in my view is
the person knew things that they can
that they have the perfect answer
because they almost without they think
they're going to create paradise here on
earth if their solutions are implemented
as it happens they tend to create hell's
on earth for people anybody with that
level
of certainty is almost certainly wrong
and will probably do a lot of damage so
what is in the book that would help
somebody understand a post bin Laden
period a post zawa area you know not to
have all these people that you write
about in here shake rock mines how many
of his sons were couple of songs he
killed over one of them one of those
being killed apparently he's in jail
here he's in Minnesota yeah Sheikh
Rahman yeah and I think after the after
bin Laden and I think it they were such
an unusual phenomenon I didn't see I
think when bin Laden and his top
leadership are eliminated or captured or
whatever and the terrorist training
camps in Afghanistan are closed
permanently which they are in the
process of being you know you're going
to revert to a situation that it that
existed before which was terrorism was a
a major irritant but it wasn't like the
major national security threat facing
United States which it became on
September 11 what did you think of the
decision that on the part of this
government to go after they did it I
think the network they've done a
brilliant job I mean it's very hard to
fault them on anything I mean it it you
know it is clear from benign statements
that they possibly possesses some sort
of radioactive weapon not an atomic
weapon and convential so I mean with
this group all bets are off so you know
in a very aggressive effort to kind of
get them I mean it's quite clear banana
has no qualms about killing civilians
including Muslim civilians because he's
killed a lot of them whether it was in
the World Trade Center attacks or in the
US Embassy bombing attacks you know the
US Embassy bombing attacks killed 200
Africans and Kenya and Tanzania are
about 30 percent Muslim so up till the
you know he turned he killed a lot more
Muslims and Americans up til September
11th you know and so this he doesn't
have you know there were no the no
checks for Bernard there's no I think if
you know he he and his followers are
ready to do as much damage as they can
and so at that point is a pure matter of
self-preservation I mean I'm not a sort
of militaristic sort of person but you
know if there's ever reason to go to
wall the the catastrophic death of you
know thousands of civilians and on doing
in a very aggressive way I mean how
could you fault that
we'll go back to when we started talking
about your life at ABC is M but what was
that what you call that first job desk
assistant oh just a desk and you you
were you were basically a gofer could go
for yeah and how many short ears what
that was the date of that again I was in
that's out of 85 85 to to 2001 what's
what's this impact on your life this
okay this book your knowledge about that
part of the world this story what are
you are you back with CNN full-time no
no I mean I I'd like to continue working
with CNN and sort of in a part-time
capacity I mean I've worked for 15 years
now for other organization and he sent
that are we possible to be independent
I'd like to do that right other books
and perhaps other articles and but the
impact of this book of my life but I
mean I hope that I can write another
book actually I mean you know about the
impact of this whole story anyone well I
mean it was it's been very hard enough
it's been very hard sometimes because
you know the events I was here in
Washington or September 11th and the
whole thing was I don't know if we were
very dreadful really the whole I found
it and and and we're worried you when it
home my father was washing television he
told me that plane it hit the Trade
Center and and sometimes he's fond of
sort of not very funny jokes and I
thought he was joking but when I came
down and saw it and then the second
plane hit and as soon as that happened I
was called up Keith McCallister the
national editor of CNN he's and his
office that just you know come here
immediately and he was pretty obvious to
anybody who followed these things it was
bin Laden and I took a cab in and and I
was it was very you remember the day was
very unclear about what was happening
who what were the targets I mean I
remember there was a report that the
State Department's perhaps on fire have
been bombed and the Pentagon was on fire
and it always reports and then suddenly
this other report came in and it's like
much stronger that's a more urgent
report you know the entire tower of the
Trade Center collapsed and my Ethiopian
cab driver I'll never forget it you just
burst into tears and it was very obvious
I mean I person it is well actually
because it just you know you knew how
many people that don't mean I thought I
knew how many people have died in that
attack and it was it was very hard to go
on but
you know I I you know I went to a CNN
and I was talking to one of the
correspondence there and I was saying
yeah maybe CNN isn't such a smart place
to be either I mean who knows it wasn't
clear wasn't clear what the objective
was I mean so it was a very difficult
day and then anyway the main thing about
it is that it it sort of gives me no joy
that the book is going to be more widely
read I mean Sonny did you did you know
it would be far better to rewind the
clock back if it you're one of the
things that strike me about bin Laden is
it he says a sort of James Bond villain
in a way but if it was a real James Bond
movie you know the treat you know James
Bond would have come in and got rid of
bin Laden the trade centres would be
standing and unfortunately life's not a
movie I mean the the trade centres foul
and bin Laden is you know able to get
away with it if you go back to that
meeting you had with him in 1997 yeah
what are the other little things that
you remember from that meeting
circumstance circumstances he at the end
of the meeting he he he was he didn't
want to hang around for very long but he
served us some cups of cup of tea
I remember himself and he lingered just
basically have some pictures taken and
we got some other other shots of him and
he the Peter on edit interview Saddam
Hussein in during the Gulf War and so
Peter on that talk to him about Saddam
Hussein he said a very interesting thing
he said Saddam Hussein's a bad Muslim
and he sees Kuwait for his own
self-aggrandizement both of which have
factually correct statements but it kind
of it was an early indicated to me that
bin Laden in bin Laden regards him like
Saddam Hussein it's basically a heretic
so the nose you shake hands with it I
don't think so I don't think so I don't
think it was ever just the situation
ever came up whether it was a shake for
Hannah or not he just he just sat down I
don't think we shook hands at all no
come to think of it I never really
thought about it until I what about the
people around him we talked a little bit
about that earlier did they know who you
were did they have a grasp of what you
were going to do with it oh yeah I think
so I mean the Sunday the translator
spoke excellent English then they big
number the people knew that you know
they understood it was CNN they
that it was an interview do they watch
CNN not in that kind of time because
some most places to have electricity you
report in the book that he bought a
$7,500 satellite telephone in New York
for 75 or so from a New York company
yeah but then abandoned the use of the
satellite telephone right probably he
banded it maybe personally I mean his
his his aides may have used that same
satellite phone and he he's not stupid
and he understood that the you know
voice print his voice print is
distinctive and you know the satellites
sweep looking for this voice and a 97
his colleague in London said that bin
Laden was not chatting away on a
satellite phone because he's very he's
been the subject of a number of other
serious assassination attempts by his
native Saudi government so he's very
very very security-conscious looking
back in a couple minutes do yeah what
what job do you think what look how
would you grade the media during this
period of time and as all that you knew
about this have you often looked at the
set or read an article and see a bunch
of misinformation I think overall the
media's that particularly after
September the media has done an amazing
job I think CNN's done a very good job I
think the New York Times should be
rewarded you know twenty Pulitzers
tomorrow
I think the Washington Post is done a
very good job I mean the fact is if you
one thing that strikes me Brian is very
interesting if you do polls on on the
relative standing the media between on
September 10th the media was regarded
with lawyers when we were talking about
Gary Condit and stuff down at 20% and
now we're doing the job the public needs
to do and we're up it you know whatever
70 or 80 percent I mean so the public
you know I think it sort of unleashed a
lot of people to actually do the jobs
they wanted I mean no one really wants
to cover Gary Condit or that kind of
stuff at the end of the day what would
you like to do next
specifically what topic what area I
would like to go back to Afghanistan and
find out what happened I think when the
smoke clears a bit you know and I mean a
lot of other things are going on right
now but I think you the opportunity to
go back to Afghanistan and talk to some
of the players find out how this all
happened and sort of basically the part
2 of this book as it were where we go
first well I'd go to probably go to
Kabul this because you need to get that
various permissions and talk to the
people that are you gonna look for to
talk to well I think you know the two
people are going to know a lot
about the situation of doctor repealed
of the Foreign Minister Abdullah has
been tracking the bin Laden group for
years because they were fighting the bin
Laden group on the front lines with the
Taliban and also you know the Karzai's
in Kandahar they're going to be people
who have information about what was the
final disposition of where mother Omar
was and what was the final werewolves in
large I mean all these these are the
people going to really know what
happened on the ground and you what's
your suspicion as to how the United
States got the tape that is a very good
question I just have no idea I mean they
aren't saying so it sounds like somebody
left the house in a hurry and just left
the tape and maybe was mislabeled I mean
you work in the day you know how often
takes get mislabeled or whatever I don't
know it just it was a mistake somebody
left it that is there a moral to all
this story people who have got on people
who believe that God is really on that
side you know it's very unlikely that
God has decided to get on your side I
mean I don't think God works like that
and bin Laden really believes that God
got on his side and that's it's not a
very useful way of looking at the world
I mean and also if you believe that God
is on your side you believe everything
you can do is is divinely sanctioned and
therefore anything you do is right it's
a very dangerous thing this is the cover
of the book it's called holy war Inc
inside the secret world of Osama bin
Laden our guest has been Peter L Bergen
thank you very much thank you sir